[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
we help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual
amazing relationships
rachel cruz number one best-selling
author three times over
and uh ramsey personality and my
daughter is my co-host today open phones
at triple eight eight two five five two
two five that's triple eight eight two
five five two two
mark starts off this hour in chattanooga
hey mark welcome to the ramsey show
hey how you doing
uh better than your phone what's up
that's better mark yes that's better
sorry so my question is i'm doing baby
steps i'm on number two i'm
self-employed it's just me sole
proprietor and um my accountant is
telling me that i'm on track this year
to end up on the irs from between five
and six grand
he's saying if you're thinking about
buying a truck for your business this is
the time to do it so you will have that
as the right office to the painted end
of the irs
but he doesn't really
explain it in a way that i can
understand it
he's a good accountant but he can't
explain anything very well
so
is this a good move or not
it's a great question were you planning
on buying a truck mark
not really i have a truck it is getting
old
but it's still good enough
okay
uh mark i've got really bad news
you need to fire your accountant
he's an idiot
okay let me let me tell you why he's an
idiot here's the math
if you buy a 30 000 truck and write it
off over three years you get to write
off ten thousand dollars a year
if you're in a 25 tax bracket that saves
you 2
in taxes
in year one two and three
okay
and so you just wrote a thirty thousand
dollar check to uh offset a twenty five
hundred dollar expense and oh by the way
you have a 5 000 expense so you have to
buy a 60 000 truck to offset 5k this
year
this guy's a [ __ ] okay
okay
that's dumb okay you follow me that's
just dumb now if you need a 60 000 or 30
000 or 10 000 truck for your business
because you can make more on your
business as a result of having invested
in equipment that is the only time in
business that we buy things we do not
ever buy things solely for the write-off
because a write-off is a tax deduction
not a tax credit meaning that you take a
if i do a ten thousand dollar expense
and i'm in a 25 tax bracket it saves me
2 500 i'm trading a dollar for a quarter
got a good trade
okay i might okay mark i feel i feel the
the wheels turning go back to what you
just said the very beginning dave
go slow in that when you said you'd have
to buy a 30 000 because it's not a
credit it's not like oh you can use you
have to write off 5 000 so you could go
get a 5 000 truck and have it paid for
for the taxes you were you know what i'm
saying like
your taxes never pay for the item
ever because you get a tax deduction
which means the amount of money that you
spend on the item in business is expense
if it's a business expense
comes off of your taxable income
so you're gonna if you if you spend ten
thousand dollars on an item for business
then that means you don't pay taxes on
ten thousand dollars of your income
because you just expensed it
you did not make as much profit
in other words you follow me
got it and so what it does is it saves
you the taxes on the ten thousand
dollars which would be about twenty five
hundred dollars three thousand dollars
something like that it does not save you
ten thousand dollars so there's no time
in the equation ever that you put out
ten thousand dollars and it saves you
ten thousand dollars in taxes
there's only one time that happens and
it's one percent of the time it's called
a tax credit and it never applies to
these situations that we're talking
about here and so anytime your
accountant tells you people out there in
the world that have a business that you
need to go buy something to save on
taxes
he or she is saying
please it is my advice for you to go
trade a dollar for a quarter
okay now if you want to need need to buy
something for your business again
separate discussion
not taxes but you want to if you want to
spend money on your business and it's
gonna make you more than it costs you
that's called an investment and that's
what we always do in business
and i spent more than ten thousand
dollars probably in the last few minutes
here and i don't even know what i did
with it been around this place but and
mark two i would say earlier too when
you mention that he can't explain stuff
to where you can really understand
that's an issue too and that's true with
your investment professional that you're
working with that's true with your
insurance tax pros i mean anyone that's
in these really niche parts of your life
and your money that
save or cost you a lot
and handle that part you really want to
know the ins and outs so the fact that
he keeps talking over your head and you
can't just use layman terms to sit there
and explain it to me
that's that's a big red flag too so the
kind of investment you do is you go okay
if we had an extra truck
uh we could make another hundred
thousand dollars a year
because that truck would generate that
much revenue the fact that we had that
truck would help us generate revenue if
you can make an extra hundred thousand
dollars a year and you want to spend
twenty thousand dollars and you have
twenty thousand dollars in cash and buy
a truck well you do that all day long
okay can i ask you this so i was on
instagram i know i know i know we're
about to go down this rabbit hole
prepare your hearts everyone and it was
on uh like in your algorithm there's
like a part that just like feeds you
content right that you just look up and
it's just random stuff other stuff
you've looked at so it's sending you
crap because you had previously been to
crap sites i don't know maybe or it says
oh they like this so this this okay so
one of mine came up and it said on the
screen and it was a real so you can see
it was a video and it said something
like the smartest
the smartest purchase
rich people make and it's a private
plane on the real so i was like oh
that's fascinating so i click on it and
basically the the guy was saying
one of the smartest ways for people one
of the smartest and i don't know if you
use the word investments purchases
for
rich people to make are private planes
because they can ride it off within
their business it's not the luxury end
it's not the
convenience but they can write it off so
again i know we're talking about a truck
and i just jumped over i'm like yeah you
jumped you jumped to a jet i jumped like
way ahead i know but same philoso with
that would that be because you can only
write it off to the extent you use it
for for business
and so if a rich person buy has a
business and they buy a jet yes okay
and
the only thing they do is fly their
family on vacation
they cannot write the jet off at all
yes but if they use it for business a
hundred percent for business they can
write it off a hundred percent okay but
it's the same thing with the truck yes
it's the same thing with a computer yeah
but to save on taxes like but the
write-off it's still but you're still
buying
deductions stream
yeah pricing
there are there are a few items in the
current tax law that's shifting very
rapidly that can all be written off in
one year
okay and a jet happens so is my guy
right on instagram
no he's not cause in the same vein of
the truck still if you spend 10 million
dollars on chat yeah okay and you use it
a hundred percent for business yeah and
you write off a hundred percent of the
ten million dollars
you still only saved
if you're in a forty percent tax bracket
then you just only say four million
dollars
not if it's not the full still spent ten
cost you a little less after taxes sure
but just like the truck
it's not free you need to go spend more
money to save money is mathematical
horse crap
whether you put millions on it or ten
thousand dollars we need it that's the
bow we needed america there it is right
there mathematical horse crap we're not
sure what that is all right this is the
ramsey show
[Music]
chaos that's what it can feel like when
your business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard go to netsuite.com
ramsey right now to get their free
whitepaper jumpstart your cfo career
[Music]
so
[Music]
rachel cruz ramsey personality number
one best-selling author is my co-host
today a lot of people would rather spend
their weekend doing yard work and talk
about insurance these are not too good
choices
uh here's the deal if you don't take the
time to learn about this stuff you'll
always feel like you're getting ripped
off in insurance and it's probably
because you are around here we think
learning about money should be simple
even fun our new
confidence in your coverage
your free five-day guide to insurance
makes learning about insurance quick and
practical and free
and you might even laugh out loud a time
or two because it is of course our one
and only george camel ramsey personality
will walk you through a new insurance
topic
unpacking everything you need to get the
right coverage for you to top it off
we're doing a giveaway for the folks who
sign up we'll have even more details on
that coming soon at the end of the
series you'll still have yard work but
at least you'll know your stuff when it
comes to insurance go to
ramseysolutions.com
confidence sign up it's free
george campbell is funny and informative
check it out ramseysolutions.com
confidence our question of the day comes
from blinds.com find out for yourself
why blinds.com is the number one online
retailer of custom window coverings you
get free samples free shipping with the
new promos they run every month you'll
save even more use the promo code ramsay
to get the best possible deal today's
question comes from angela in south
carolina my husband and i are closing
soon on the sale of 27 acres that my
parents gave us to avoid taxes on the
1.8 million that we will receive at
closing we are looking at these options
buying an airbnb or rental property or
putting the money in real estate
in a real estate investment trust
company or adding it
in our roth accounts we have a financial
advisor however we listen to the show
and know that you have much wisdom to
offer we want to be good stewards of the
money what should we do with this money
dun dun dun 1.8 million
i hate it when that happens
man that's awesome very cool
so a 1031 tax deferred exchange is
section 1031 in the irs code and it
allows you to sell a piece of property
into a 1031
escrow account it's a specialized screw
account it costs you about fifteen
hundred dollars to set it up you need to
do it before you close on the property
and uh so you're gonna spend 1500 bucks
you're going to park the money in there
you have 45 days to identify
the properties that you're going to
purchase
with that money
and you have 180 days to close
on the properties it has to be real
estate properties that you're going to
purchase with that money that would move
the entire amount into other real estate
investments with zero taxes
now you will pay taxes someday when you
sell that other property but
if you sell it while you're alive
but um
uh i'm in the midst of doing one of
those transactions right now i sold
a piece of real estate that we had and i
closed it into a 1031 and i'm looking
for what i'm going to buy with it so
that i don't have to pay the taxes on
the gain
in your case the gain is going to be a
lot
um it's not the whole 1.8 but it's a lot
yeah so because your basis on the
property is whatever your parents that
gave it to you paid for it
and so if they paid a hundred thousand
dollars for it and you sold it for 1.7
then your gain is or your and you sold
it for 1.8 and your gain is 1.7 it's
almost the whole stinking thing in other
words so yeah set their tax bracket
would it be taxed at their tax bracket
or is that no it's a capital gains rate
15
15 capital gains rate but the uh the
thing is this
what i would do is uh buy other real
estate with it because you
the way she
phrased this is that that was
comfortable to her
right
uh putting part of the money in real
estate or real estate investment trust i
mean you can do that you cannot put it
into a roth the roth is not like kind
uh putting it in roth doesn't she
doesn't achieve a single thing so you
don't need to do a roth ira what's your
feeling about investment like companies
that you put money in and you own
properties all over with a with a group
of people you don't do that personally i
know but like is that are you well
there's several different kinds the ones
that are safe
and i don't know if that qualifies for a
1031 you'd have to ask your tax on this
because when you're doing a 1031 has to
be a like-kind exchange yeah so you had
to sell a piece of ground a piece of
real estate and buy a piece of real
estate i'm not sure if you bought a real
estate investment trust if that's going
to count that's the same so what a reit
is uh uh reit is a basically it's a
mutual fund for real estate it's way
functions there's a whole bunch of
people put money into this mutual fund
and they buy real estate with it so they
may buy apartments
they might buy
you know god help them shopping malls
probably not but uh uh you know office
buildings whatever and every so often
all those properties will sell but it
all just stays inside of that reit and
if you can put the money in that then
that's a uh
the reits in the old days were heavy on
fees and the net on them was not as good
as a regular mutual fund and certainly
not as good as real estate these days
the reits are strong
and you can because there's like the
marketplace just demanded they quit
feeding their butt off and so they they
got their fees up to where they got
their fees down where they're reasonable
to run this multi-billion dollar you
know trust and um
so they're they're they're actually very
they're getting good rates of return as
good as as good as growth stock mutual
funds are better in some cases if you
just shop around your advisor can
probably help you with that so for
someone like angela that may not want to
fool with a rental property
yeah like if they're like oh we don't
want to deal with it i mean you're going
from airbnb which is about the highest
hassle
yeah drive you crazy type of rental
property yeah because you have a renter
that's in there for two freaking days
you know and so that that's like the
worst
in terms of hassle factor but great
rates of return if you want to screw
with it all the way over to rental
property and then all the way over your
reach so she's got all three types on
there like no maintenance no no hassle
to the worst hassle
on her list here so i'm thinking she can
find something in there that's
reasonable rates of return oh yeah uh
with that million dollars i mean you can
go buy a little office building a little
strip center um
and and you know
manage it it's not it's not that hard to
manage or put a property manager on it
and not pay the taxes i really would
since she's not averse to real estate i
would i would look at a 1031
and uh and no the um
that's it
there's no i would not do the roth it
doesn't work it doesn't fit and i'm not
sure the requalifies you'd have to ask
and find out
and um
and you can't it's not for your personal
residence this is investment property
transactions all of these are investment
property transactions your personal
residences does not qualify for a 1031
because you when you sell your personal
residence married filing jointly you can
make a half a million dollars profit
without having any taxes and everything
after that is taxed period
um and so that you cannot get around
that it's it's part of the deal
so all right open phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five daniel
is in pennsylvania hi daniel how are you
hi good thank you for taking my call
sure what's up
i need your help on how to move from a
bad history of acquiring debt
failing to keep up with those payments
due to an issue with gambling
and now moving into a point of ownership
and understanding my responsibility
as a father and as a husband to lead my
family into a prosperous future
wow
that sounds like a story
how long you been dry um
well it's uh
going on in over a year now a little
over a year um that i finally said call
it quit but
how did you quit did you get some help
or you just decided you're not gonna
gamble it was kind of cold turkey but i
had to um i had to um
remove myself from those situations um
by self-exclusion yeah did you did you
join like gamblers anonymous or anything
uh i did not okay all right good for you
it's amazing what were you betting on
uh usually tables mostly tables okay
online too online is very dangerous yeah
it's very dangerous it's uh
second fastest growing addiction in
america today online gambling
it's destroying families we're seeing it
everywhere and this sports bet and and
uh you know it's not it's not a moral
judgment it's just destroying families
we're seeing the sports betting is
blowing people up good friend of ours
the other day that just blew up their
whole marriage the whole thing's gone
just lost everything but not stupid
games so daniel for you is that where to
go way to go man i'm proud of you
amazing is there current debt that
you're having
to pay off uh yeah there's quite a bit
of debt um i'm sure some debts i don't
know about i would estimate 50 to 60.
what do you mean
between my wife and i um probably about
60 per year okay how much doubt have you
got
um i'm guessing between 50 and 60. okay
good we can get you out brother we want
to participate in your healing we're
going to put you into financial peace
university you and your wife go through
that as our guest uh hang on and austin
will sign you up man and you call us
back and let us know how you're doing
i'm proud of you you're breaking a big
time cycle there you can do this but you
do need to put some systems in place to
do it
[Music]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice
basically they care that's why we call
them ramsey trusted you can achieve
debt-free home ownership and churchill
is here to help go to their site
churchhillmortgage.com
ramsey to start your approval or get
more information
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
rachel cruz ramsey personality is my
co-host today
join us at ramsey solutions we have a
nice visitor center here in franklin
tennessee just south of wonderful
nashville tennessee
and franklin's even better than
nashville by the way so but come on out
and visit either one of us the uh the
lobby here is quite an experience you
can watch the show from one to four
central time we do it live every day for
600 plus radio stations and about 20
million of you in podcasts and youtubes
and so forth out there and uh the coffee
is free the entrance is free the
homemade chocolate chip cookies are free
and the debt free stage is right in the
middle of it and that's where devin and
regina are hey guys how are you not bad
good how are you dave good to have you
guys where do you live
springfield missouri oh fun welcome to
nashville how much debt have you paid
off
113
803
and some change good for you how long
did this take
around 20 months good for you wow and
your range of income during that time
um 100 to about 140. good what do you
guys do for a living
i'm a surgical technologist in
springfield and um
devon well
i own uh i own a lawn care company but
during the debt free during the
debt-free journey did multiple
side hustles so oh cool what was your
best side hustle the one that made the
most money um probably at the time i was
i was working full time um so probably
the the lawn care but that's what i took
full time um so after that would
probably been driving uber and lyft
okay that's awesome good very good good
for you well done what kind of debt was
your 114 000
we had a little bit of everything
uh we had a lot of medical bills
from
between i had a
surgery he had some
things done and then
our oldest daughter has epilepsy and so
through testing and this and that we had
a lot of medical bills
a couple cars a heloc
a
mower um
she looks at him
you know a couple small credit cards and
then that were normal yeah normal socks
and the stupid tax with the timeshare
oh just put the icing on the cage right
there that's a whole nother story yeah
that's a whole nother episode yes
legalized fraud called timeshares
unbelievable way to go you guys all
right so what happened 20 months ago
that set you on fire
um kind of like you say i was sick and
tired of being sick and tired
and i had had a surgery and
things were building up and we had a
decent income coming in but we had no
idea where it was going
um
and i knew i was tired of living
paycheck to paycheck mm-hmm but the
surgery kind of jolted you absolutely
i had a little bit of time on my hands
uh yeah you had an extra bill that you
didn't have before that and you're like
oh my god we gotta fix this yeah and so
i knew that he had um he wasn't real
happy at his full-time job and he had a
desire to
have his own business
and
one day i was just sitting there and i
was like the only way we can do this is
if we become debt free and so i broke it
to him
you broke it too
so what did you say devon i was i was on
board i mean we we'd been davish you
know in the past and and then the the
kids were born and we had the medical
bills and we kind of fell off and and
then when she said it i was like i know
it works so let's just do it and and get
it done so you you get out the old uh
total money makeover book and dust it
off or what yes
exactly literally okay
go back through financial peace
university or what we didn't we just um
just did the book we we knew what to do
but now it's time yes now it's time just
game on exactly yeah i love it well done
good way to go congratulations thank you
amazing amazing okay so how long have
you guys been married
12 years 12 years okay so what does that
look like now and with your kids how
many kids do y'all have two two girls so
what is that as a family doing this so
it's like you've been in a habit for a
certain period of time right in marriage
and with your family and you guys 20
months ago shifted the way that you're
doing life so how
how was building those new habits and
saying okay we're going to we're going
to change the way we've been handling
money how hard was it how did that feel
with your family dynamic because a lot
of people listening you know have been
married for your time and have kids and
they're fearful to step into change
well i'll say it was tough at first but
knowing that we could do it i mean
you know knowing the plan works
and as i just saw on the youtube channel
there um we wanted to take our kids to
disney and and we wanted to do that
debt-free not bring that home with us
and so we you know we told the girls
like hey this is what we're going to do
and if we if we accomplish this then
we're going to disney and so we went to
disney in march and we did that
completely different i love it i love it
came home and it did so they're holding
you accountable big time oh for
sure absolutely i mean
they were with us every step of the way
and you know i'd pay off a bill and i'd
let them know
like we celebrated we celebrated every
one of them that's awesome and after we
paid off the the last one and they knew
it and they're like we go to disney this
weekend
it's like
no
now we've got to save for that
this weekend but now we do get to go yes
i love it very good all right so what do
you tell people the key now that you've
done it you pay off a hundred and
fourteen thousand and twenty months
that's legitimate
what's the key to getting out of debt a
budget
i mean it's that simple um we had no
idea where our money was going
and i sat down and
i tried the spreadsheet thing i tried
you know the phone apps and i can i
needed a pencil and a paper
and i sat down he made fun of me a lot i
would come home and be like you know
cause she's every night she was you know
looking at that and i'm like you know
it's not gonna change overnight like yes
it does but it did it
does and so you know how the nerds free
spirit are now yeah
we can yeah that's good i like it though
but no the budget was huge
now you knew how to do a budget before
what do you think i mean
something that after the surgery he's
tired of living paycheck to paycheck the
extra bill comes in you say enough's
enough
how how do you tell people out there
that are kind of they've been going
along ramsey-ish
and okay now it's time to get off the
center they know how to do a budget too
right
but what is it that moves you from ish
to game on what is what happens down
inside of you
you just have to you have to see that
big picture you know and that's what i
did i saw the i saw going to disney i
saw going on out on my own you know
owning my own business
and just seeing that that bigger picture
um that that just really changed me um
i wanted just to be able to
make a future for our family yeah again
yeah a vision a big picture yeah yeah
you got to have something bigger than i
i'd like to be out of debt and that you
don't like to be out of that won't do it
right but something that it did for our
relationship too though um i would like
get sick to my stomach because i
wouldn't know
like okay we've got ten dollars until
you know we get paid again and she
didn't she didn't want to tell me that
you know i mean yeah
a lot of shame yeah yes i and i kept it
all in it's like okay we can't end so
i'd end up i'd send him a text hey
don't go purchase anything today or go
and so when we started this budget and
started the plan it was
i was very open i felt like okay he
knows what we're trying to do here and
um
we were able to talk about it you quit
carrying the whole thing on your back
absolutely both of you are carrying it
now yep that's huge so and the freedom
of it the isolation that you feel right
of just it's all here and i can't i
don't want to say it out loud because i
don't even want to know the reality like
right when you say the words it's like
but now that it's out there there's like
a freedom to it i love that and you guys
working on a team working as a team
together yes so proud of y'all way to go
thanks dave rock stars we got a copy of
baby steps millionaires for you that's
the next chapter in your story how
ordinary people built extraordinary
wealth how you can as well
and of course a copy of total money
makeover and we're going to give you a
financial peace university one year
subscription to ramsey plus get you into
fpu and into every dollar plus if you
don't want to eat any of that you can
always give it away pay it forward
because people are going to be asking
what happened to you your faces have
changed life is good i love it all right
what are the kids names and ages
we have delaney is 10 and kenley is six
all right and they look like disney
veterans to me
all right 114 000 paid off in 20 months
making 100 140. count it down let's hear
a debt free screen okay
three
two
one
[Music]
[Applause]
those girls lives are changed because
their parents are heroes
it changed everything man and nobody
fixed it but them
nobody's coming you got to fix it it's
your job be a grown-up this is the
ramsey show
[Music]
um
[Music]
rachel cruz ramsey personality is
my co-host today here on the ramsey show
dustin's with us in phoenix arizona hi
dustin how are you
hey i'm well dave how are you better
than i deserve what's up
uh so i have a unique situation um
my wife and i got together a few years
ago um
at the time we're both in our 30s both
owned homes
and um
both homes weren't worth a whole lot
as far as as much as we'd make for them
so we decided to rent one out well you
know markets going crazy here
um we are on baby step two
and we are trying to pay off debt
and um
i know i'll never be able to get a
rental property again for as little as i
paid for what we have right now
we didn't really set out to be landlords
or anything like that but
we were just wondering is now the time
should we sell it go ahead and pay off
debt pay off our house and just kind of
um
completely skip step two that way
how much how much can you sell the
rental property for
um
roughly net i make about 240 000. you'd
make that okay and how much is your debt
um
with
car and
credit card debts we got about 57 000
um
the leftover mortgage on the house we're
currently in is about 153 000
and how much do you guys make a year
combined uh around uh 176 000.
100 and what 76. 70. oh dang yeah you're
killing it well done oh man
okay so dustin the way we answer
questions around here is knowing what i
know after 30 years of doing this and
living these principles myself
and rachel growing up on them and
writing and talking about them all over
america what will we do if we woke up in
your shoes okay
i love rental property i'm a real estate
guy so that's self to claim or uh
disclaimer there okay
um
but if i woke up in your shoes i also
love being debt free and i actually love
that more than i love rental property
because being debt free allows me to
save up and pay cash for rental property
uh or save up and pay cash for whatever
i want to do because if you make 176 000
you don't have a payment in the world
and you actually live on a budget and
you live with intentionality like a
grown-up
and not like you're in congress right
spending
but i'm talking about really write it
down know where your money's going you
and your spouse are in agreement
and we have some goals with the money we
have some generosity goals some
investment goals and some enjoyment
goals and they're all part of that you
got so much stinking money coming in
with no payments in the world you can
buy another rental property fairly quick
that's what we kind of figured if that's
the route we even want to go you know
exactly yeah
for sure
and you're not even sure you love this
it's by default as you said it wasn't by
plan
yeah it wasn't you know we just knew we
weren't going to make much off it at the
time so
hold on to it um at the time i currently
had a family member that was
um in need of a place so we just said
okay go ahead and start paying rent yeah
um and uh and now i feel like kind of
the time to do it because if we don't do
it now um i'll probably have to pay
capital gains on it but i'm still within
the two-year window right now so
it's kind of like now or never you know
yeah oh that's great
yeah you could take the personal
exemption i don't pay no taxes oh this
is wonderful okay so dustin my only word
of caution
because yes i think sell it payoff did
all of it so there is something to be
said though about the debt-free journey
that people go through like this couple
that just was on the segment before 20
months of sacrifice and all that so
when i hear people go through a journey
like that
more than likely they're not going back
in debt because they felt the pain of
the sacrifice to get out you guys
in a wonderful blessing
uh
are going to get it paid it off with you
know selling this rental property which
is amazing but you found a genie and you
said give me three wishes right one of
them's like get free right yeah and you
get to be it so just don't go back to
your bad habits because nothing's going
to break those bad habits of the time of
sacrifice you know what i'm saying of
like
a debt-free journey that we hear a lot
on these on the show so you and your
wife together you guys have to like
pinky promise
in writing black and white we are not
going back into these habits and we're
going to take 176 000 and write it down
every month where it's going on purpose
yes and stick to that i don't care where
it goes as long as both of you are in on
it and both of you do it on purpose and
because you're not going to do stupid on
purpose
stupid is always an accident
it's always like i was just driving by
the car lot and there's a porsche who
knew you know and so you know stupid is
never but if you save up and pay cash
for a porsche i mean then that's okay
right and so you've got the money to do
whatever you want but don't let bass
boats jump into the driveway you know
and they will they'll just pop in there
i've seen it happen and so it's it's a
problem and so on paper on purpose
before the month begins the rest of your
life if you can make that promise to
yourselves for the good of yourselves no
more debt no more debt cut up the credit
cards get be done be done you can do
that then yes yes i would sell the
rental property and i'd be dead free
tomorrow it's amazing and you're going
to have this sense of peace that you had
no idea was going to flood over you
you're going to wake up and go
wow i feel like i just lost 300 pounds
i just feel like a different person and
they get to pay off their their current
house too i mean they're paying off
their mortgage everything they're
jumping and then you're going to use
some of that for an emergency fund too
justin yeah or dustin i'm sorry uh i
mean you guys will you'll be skipping
basically right to baby step
7 with this it's amazing exactly well
done
alan's in tampa hey alan how are you
hey mr dave miss rachel how are you
great what's up
well
i'm
looking to change careers and it's going
to
cost me about
10 grand to
do an online course to do this
and i recently sold
an extra vehicle that i had i'm in baby
step two
and so i have the cash to do this course
but i'm really tempted to just throw it
at the debt instead
and then
they have a month month-to-month option
on this course it's not uh financing
it's if you don't pay
you they just pause the the program and
until you have the money to continue it
so how long does it take to do it um
nine months
okay so 1100 bucks 1100 bucks a month
what's your income
uh my income is my my take home on my
full-time job is on a 40-hour week is
right at 8 15
a week and then my second job is
right at
right at 300
a week
and then with overtime
which kind of comes and goes um and
recently it's been coming more than
going
uh and so i've been averaging right
around a thousand
um a week got my full-time job take home
but like i said that's that's not always
a thousand
in addition to your base or a thousand
total
oh a thousand total i'm sorry okay so
you're making about 5200 is your wife
work
i'm divorced oh you're single okay all
right and how much data have you got yes
sir
uh
now as of right now i'm sitting at uh
right around just a little bit over 37
grand and if you take the 10 grand
course what can you make what's the new
job pay
i've been told that entry-level position
is 80 000 a year in the state of florida
what is it
a software engineer
and you don't do any coding now
no sir i'm starting from ground zero
okay yeah you'd be dev one
that's what you'd be coming out right
you're going to code school right
yes sir yeah okay good i like it i want
you to do the code i want you to coach
because great upside potential for you
if it fits your personality style i
would go with it for sure how much debt
you say you had again
i'm sitting at uh 37 a little over 37
000 how much of that's your car
uh 18.
it doesn't matter
go to code school it doesn't matter
which way whether you pay it monthly or
whether you pay another you're going to
get out of debt exactly the same period
of time
um
the thing is you're probably going to
have to lower your income while you're
going to code school because you're
going to be working as much
uh that's that factor yeah yeah you're
gonna have to drop off some of your ot
and or your side hustle so that's going
to go down
for your income's you may end up you may
end up needing to sell the car before
it's over
uh but i'm going to coach school and
then i'm going to work my way through
this as fast as i can
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
hey it's rachel cruz co-host on the
ramsay show if you want to do your
debt-free stream live on the show visit
ramseysolutions.comfreescreen
we'd love for you to come to nashville
and tell dave your story that's
ramseysolutions.com
debt free screen
[Music]
this is the ramsey show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
the ramsey show is where we help people
build wealth
do work that they really love and create
actual amazing relationships
rachel cruz ramsey personality number
one best-selling author is my co-host
today open phones at
eight two five five two two five
michael is in miami hey michael welcome
to the ramsey show
hey dave hey guys how are we doing
better than i deserved sir what's up
uh not much uh i'm uh 28 as you said
here from miami and i'm self-employed i
would manage my to get myself out of 60
000 in debt which took me uh about a
year to do good and
yeah thank you sir and my question is
i'm currently renting now and i've
managed to save up 550 000
and
i honestly don't know
what the best thing to do as far as
investment wise and i'm honestly looking
into buying a house and buying the cash
and you know i know you're the perfect
person to talk to about it so i want to
um you know see what the best way to go
about it is dude you went from 60 grand
getting out of debt to 550 000 in the
bank like it was nothing what the flip
did you do
oh well i i took a lot of lumps in uh
like four different businesses that i
started one of which was the reason i
got into the debt you know because i got
started with like 5 000 and the rest was
credit card so i made some big mistakes
when i was younger
and i've always been a serial
entrepreneur and you know this last one
i started uh it's going on a year and a
half now i've due to all the mistakes
i've learned from have
allowed me to make it uh make it work
okay so you just you've you hit a lick
with your business all right good and it
was kind of after you got clear of the
debt
yes sir wow that's interesting well
before technically now you have to
struggle to get out of the debt and then
that allowed me to be in a position to
start the business and then
make it work not off of debt no i'm
saying the 550 000 all came
after you cleared the debt
yes sir yeah that's what i was trying to
get my hands around good good for you
well done proud of you man
i feel that feels pretty studly doesn't
it
oh man it's it's amazing you know the
challenges come up and you just gotta
persevere and uh you know stay true to
your gut yeah
so have you looked michael at houses in
your area that you want to live for that
amount of money
oh yeah i can get a
nice 1-1 around here in miami these are
some of the most outrageous prices i've
seen and part of the reason why i'm
still renting is the red hot market and
i know the market's kind of tapering
down a little bit around you know
everywhere else but uh yeah you know
it's it's rough out here yeah it really
is yeah one and one's about all you're
gonna get in in miami proper in dade
for that because it's an expensive
market
it kind of thinks it's new york um
wow i mean pretty pretty cool okay so
here's the thing
a couple of observations about your
situation
number one i'm gonna send you a copy
of the book baby steps
millionaires that shows you what
millionaires have done we studied in the
back of it is a synopsis of the study a
white paper of the study of the largest
study of millionaires ever done in north
america airtight research so these are
what is are known as facts not opinions
with your broke brother-in-law
okay
these are facts
now
the biggest thing that we found
was the biggest correlation that we
found among the first people to have a
million a million to a eight million
dollar five million dollar net worth the
first one to five million dollars in net
worth
comes from two things
a paid for house
and a fully funded rocking 401k roth ira
investment retirement program
okay
so we often found a 42 year old
that wasn't making anywhere near as much
as you're making and so it took them to
42.
and they had a million in their 401k and
a paid for six hundred thousand dollar
house so their net worth was a million
six
we found
thousands of those
that we interviewed they're all over the
place okay so what that tells us is if
you want to be one of those that's your
two best
routes to get there paid for house fully
funding loading up retirement
okay the danger of how the wonderful
experience you've had is it's the same
thing that happened to me in my 20s i
had 4 million worth of real estate by
the time i was 26 starting from nothing
and i thought i could just do that all
the time
and and i thought that
i couldn't do anything wrong and i i
fell prey to and i want to warn you
against this the idea that i could out
earn my stupidity
no shot you know and it's because you've
been making bank and you can go i could
i could screw this up and still be okay
you know and it's it's hard to do out
here dave because uh you know i i live
in a place where what i call the flex
factor run ramp and it's uh a lot of
people you live in the ultimate flax
netflix neighborhood yeah indefinite
flex of all kinds yeah it's all flexes
there i get you
yeah for sure
and if you don't if you don't believe
that about miami just go to miami beach
okay so oh my gosh and uh uh
but it
so yeah you can really fall off into
that and and start to believe your own
handwriting so be careful
i i would continue to make money and
continue to live like i'm not making any
money
for about two more years and you're
gonna have all the money you want for
the rest of your life probably
um
are you in our your single guy
yeah i i'm with my my girlfriend and uh
we're going on about four years now so
you know a couple of milestones are
definitely around the corner for us you
know uh getting married and everything
would it be okay to go make another 500
in the next year and a half
and um bank that
and then let's talk about buying would
that be okay
yeah no absolutely like i told her and
you know her parents are in in real
estate in there in the color bay area in
miami and i'm not in any rush and you
know i saw your show yesterday and you
know what you're saying is you know you
definitely don't want you definitely if
you're going to get an investment
property make sure you're getting the
deal and deals are kind of hard to come
by right now no there's no
there's no deals yeah
well i was wondering if i should look
elsewhere you know just you know but i
don't know i mean if you wanted to move
inland and
move uh what northwest out of there um
you know a fort lauderdale direction you
know you you probably can
you probably can get your prices down
considerable and getting a lot more
reasonable thing if you want to go ahead
and get in the market that's fine i
don't i just don't hear an emergency
here for you to buy no i do want you to
buy in the next three years but i don't
know if i care if you buy in the next
three months
okay
okay yeah well i have uh i get out of
this lease in you know february of next
year yeah so you know so what would you
suggest probably starting to look into
some other uh investments maybe a mutual
fund it doesn't even have to be it's a
year
it's not even a year it's february i
mean you're going to pile up so much
more how much more can you have by
february
um
to be honest i'd say
at least another 250. yeah
it's a different discussion right yeah a
little bit of movement northwest
and another 250 in february changes it i
just think that you know and then just
be careful to not try to out earn your
stupidity
and and i i think you're a sharp young
dude man i'm proud of you you're killing
it i love entrepreneurs michael well
done and if there's a ring on her finger
she may have a say on where you guys are
going to live too if you get married so
yeah if you buy a house when you're a
single guy after you get married you'll
discover you bought the wrong house so
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
rachel cruz ramsey personality is my
co-host today if you can imagine the
energy of a jam-packed arena
filled with people ready to experience
what it means to live
life to the fullest all of your favorite
speakers on one stage empowering you
with tools and principles that will
create unstoppable momentum in your life
well that is smart conference smart
conference is back been three years and
we're so pumped to get this event back
on the road in dallas dallas texas
saturday october 22nd uh the tickets are
about half sold out we'll have about 8
000 folks there so you can still get
tickets it's not another pep talk this
is thousands of people just like you
coming together all day long on saturday
october 22nd under one roof roof to
learn how to build wealth
hit your goals strengthen your
relationships
marriage
your career your mental wellness
it's all of the ramsey personalities
you're going to have a blast and craig
and amy grochelle from life church are
going to be speaking on marriage tickets
are only 39
and guys that's a great price for a full
day event like this get your tickets now
before they sell out go to
ramseysolutions.com
events and we do have four building
wealth events in the fall they are all
80 to 85 sold out
warning they're going to be gone soon
i know they're in the fall i know it
feels like it's a long way away but
you're not going to have tickets and
that's all that's on the books guys so
if you want to come you need to get
tickets these events right now smart
conference and building wealth events
all at ramsey solutions
um can we chat real estate for like a
quick second before we get to the phones
sure okay so he just said on the last
call you know that things are kind of
slowing down and i think people were
kind of feeling that even in nashville a
little bit it's not like insane like it
was six months ago
and i've heard you say how the housing
prices
will probably not dip
down
right like 08 right so the difference
or what is the difference in the market
from 08 to now because people i've heard
people say i'm going to wait until the
prices go back down
and they're not as red hot to buy today
because the prices are crazy to buy a
house right now
um
but they won't go back
your prediction if you had a crystal
ball would that they're not going to go
back is it because the 0.8 crash had to
do around
all
the the borrowing from mortgages and
security back loans all of that is it
because that recession was fueled by the
real estate market that it went down and
this is different
or what's the what's the reason because
i hear that question constantly of like
oh people think that that the housing
prices are going to go back down
it's like it's not always
as simple as supply and demand
but it almost always is
now what causes the supply
shortage and the demand increase or the
demand to be down and the supply to go
up
is
varying things and you can start looking
at that but the the root issue of what
drives house prices almost always is
supply and demand
uh and that's true so you know the the
old joke of in an appraisal class you
know i was an appraisal class give me an
old joke of the old appraisal class
i don't know much
it's a real estate has one joke and this
is it
you know what determines the price of
real estate location location and
location
yeah but not really because
so in other words you could take a
concrete block house that's a thousand
square foot and put it in the rich into
town
and it'll bring a whole lot more than a
really nice house and the dumpy
crime ridden horrible into town right
okay so it's not the quality of the
house it's not the thing it's not the
mortgage rates it's it's where the
stinking thing sits
okay yeah people perceive that why does
that affect it well because more people
it's more desirable live over there more
people chasing that piece of dirt than
chase the dirt over in the other into
town yeah and so it is supply versus
demand ultimately now interest rates
affect that when interest rates go up
guess what fewer buyers yep so the
demand goes down
thus prices are going to soften
or not be as cray-cray as they have been
right and that's what we're seeing right
now
uh if supply can go up even if interest
rates go up if supply went up faster if
we could double the amount of houses on
the market by snapping our fingers and
interest rates went to six percent which
they are okay uh or five and some change
whatever right uh then you would see uh
demand you know that you'd still see
because there's ten houses for every two
buyers instead of two houses for every
10 buyers yeah that's the problem is
that we're always facing right is the
supply demand thing now in 2008 what
happened was there was a tremendous over
supply
because the foreclosures went everywhere
and the market just froze
nobody was buying houses had nothing to
do with the economy really had nothing
to do with interest rates it had to do
with there was a real estate panic and
people quit buying and there's this huge
supply we dumped a bazillion properties
on the market and all the buyers are
standing on the sidelines looking at it
so almost no demand huge supply so you
see one time in the last 100 years that
real estate prices actually went down
and that was 2008 but that was huge
supply almost no demand now what do we
got right now
shortage of houses
and the buyers are calming down because
interest rates are going up and supply
is catching up slowly
because some of the new housing stuff's
starting to come back on labor shortage
uh is starting to a little bit and be
alleviated some of the biden bucks are
running out people are actually having
to go back to work the um
uh uh uh lumber prices have stabilized
so new housing is coming on the market
again
at a better rate than it was say a year
and a half ago so we got a little bit of
supply up and a little bit of demand
down and so we've got a softening in the
rate of increase of price but you're not
going to see prices go down because
you're not going to see the demand
versus the supply shift enough to cause
prices to go down okay that's great
that's what i'm that's what i keep
looking at and it's nice it's really
nice
yeah it's but it is the old appraisal
class we all just got to go through
america there you go
by the old by the old guy but that's
what i wanted to know though because we
keep because i you know i mean it's
still even within our friend group it's
like people are talking about okay well
buying in this and we want to do this we
got to hold off here and you know and
you hear the rumblings of we're just
going to wait 12 months until prices go
back down but here's the reason the
economy and the stock market and real
estate is so interesting
because it really is at the end of the
day psychology
is what are the buyers going to do
what are people going to are they going
to act how they going to react
and
you know if everybody thinks facebook's
gonna be a big deal you know what
facebook stock goes up if everybody
thinks apple is the second coming of
jesus then apple stock is i mean apple
has more money than egypt
literally it's crazy and so you know uh
this kind of stuff right but but what it
amounts to is it's perception
people believe it and they make it so
it's a self-fulfilling prophecy out
there in the economy all the time and so
if enough people believe that the market
is wonderful and crazy and white hot
then they go behave like that and a an
asking price on a piece of real estate
is no lo is no longer an asking price
it's a suggested starting point
for the auction
and so because because the cray-cray
it's all the psychology on it and so but
if everybody suddenly went you know what
i'm gonna chill
boom you would you would freeze these
prices like a deer in the headlight and
so we see that like if you go all the
way back to when i was a kid like 1982
okay and carter
interest rates fixed rates for mortgages
went to 18
well guess what
no demand
but house prices still didn't go down
much yeah i mean if they did it was just
for a little bit but you couldn't give a
house away i mean if you had to sell a
house it was probably going to be maybe
a little bit of a discount
but they still sat there and then
stinking prices came down to where i'm
24 years old selling houses in 1984
at 14 fixed rates that year they
announced this brand new type of
mortgage called the adjustable rate
mortgage
and a r m
in 1984 you could get for 12 where your
fixed rate was 14
and people are lined up around the block
why because all those people that didn't
buy for the three years
prior to that because it was 18 and 17
and 16
all of them came into the market in one
year
boom market took off went crazy at 14
interest rates yeah that's nuts that's
nuts but it's all supply demand it and
underlying it now different things cause
the supply to be up or down yep the
demand to be up or down but always be
looking for that that's going to tell
you what's going to happen with the
market this is the ramsey show
[Music]
uh
[Music]
still on baby step number one huh
how'd you guess
with health care costs rising learn how
christian healthcare ministries can help
you make the most out of your budget
visit
chministries.org budget don't worry
it's worth it
[Music]
so
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage judd and christy are
with us hey guys how are you how you
doing dave great man it's good to have
you guys where do you live we live uh
sandwich illinois right outside of
naperville okay naperville illinois
awesome good to have you guys welcome to
nashville thank you and all the way here
to do a debt-free scream so let's say
gulf war veteran thank you for your
service sir thank you for your support
how much uh how much your debt do you
pay off uh around 135 000 cool how long
did that take
we started full force around uh 2017
and then just paid it off uh april 28th
paid our house off ow house and
everything
look at it where people
yep all right so 17. so five years
okay good good good for you and your
range of income during that time we
started at about a hundred and ended
about 140 000. cool what do y'all do for
a living uh i'm a paramedic firefighter
and uh union plumber and i'm a hair
stylist awesomeness very good so what
kind of debt was the 135 just the house
no we had uh we had a business
um
we had a van
and the house okay wow good for you guys
well done how's it feel to be free
uh it feels pretty good we just had our
first uh our first mortgage payment that
was supposed to go out two weeks ago so
it's uh
it still still doesn't quite hit us a
hundred percent yet and it landed
mysteriously in your account yes and and
the best part about that is is the
mortgage company hasn't released our tax
money yet so we had to dig into our
emergency fund to pay the taxes that
were due on june 1st so
hopefully when we get back home we'll
have the money that was escrowed for our
for our mortgage back from them so we'd
be able to put that back into our
insurance go into our emergency fund oh
wow they can't even do that part right
no it took them a month who was it
countrywide uh
caliber homeowners okay good good oh my
gosh you got rid of them though yep
you're done man the funny part with
caliber calibers it took us seven hours
and nine people to figure out how they
actually wanted us to send the final
payment in no and got i we also got 11
different ways they wanted us to send
the money in and it was it was it was
pretty exhausting oh my gosh yeah every
time we called and talked to somebody
different they would tell us a different
way to send it
unbelievable it was it was they wanted
to keep you guys yeah they're like no
we're making it hard
and the last month that we had our
mortgage we heard from three different
people with less than three thousand
left on our mortgage wanting to
refinance of course oh my god always
but you're done wow you are done what
started this process in 2017 well it
started a long time ago we were davis
for years our parents uh bought the
program for uh my wife and i my brother
and his wife and
we we started on it and then next time
we bought a truck
and
just just bought it and bought and paid
it off quick yeah and then we bought
another car and paid it off quick and
then we bought a camper and paid it off
and then finally just after
buying everything and and just something
clicked in in the summer of 17 and that
was it we we
uh christy had a shop that we had to
shut down just you know it wasn't it
wasn't working so we shut it down in uh
april of 19.
and right before covet hitched you know
thankfully we were able to shut it down
because
we wouldn't have been able to afford it
yeah uh we paid the van off uh and paid
the shop off
in summer of 19
and then that just ever since we had
about 85 000 left on the house and uh
dig in there just kept at it just
something in in the summer 17 just it
just clicked and and it was
it was just
full force yeah yeah way to go guys how
does it feel to be free it feels it
feels great
yeah it
we we
we we finished our last fpu class um
our first the the last
class of our first fu class
we finished that for church
and uh we did it there and we we really
pushed hard to make sure we had it done
because we were coming down here our
daughter turned 21 last week so we
wanted to bring her down for that end
roll this into there so ah push it all
together yeah good good that's amazing
you guys so what was the key
to this journey to pay off the mortgage
pay off everything the the budget budget
the
i mean
we we struggled with the budget at first
and and got better you know yes you say
three months it's it took us forever to
get it down but we kept we kept talking
about it we kept working with it and
then uh and we didn't we just finally
you know the last the last year year and
a half it's just really
we really got more in tune with it and
that's when it really started we paid
him the majority of our mortgage off in
the last year and a half christie what
was he doing to mess up her budget
[Laughter]
yeah all right good for you guys oh man
i'm awesome
everybody says that but then that
something that clicked is just as
important right i i don't know what i
don't know what it was it clicked it's
just
it's just we we we would talk about it
and you know next time we had a we had a
you know like i said a truck payment or
a camper payment or another van payment
we'd hurry up and we'd pay it off and
then we'd be debt-free for a couple of a
couple of months and the next you know
there's a new vehicle sitting in the
driveway
and it just happened just it just
happened i don't know carvana just
brought one of those little trucks over
yeah right there that's right and then
it's just like so just the summer is 17
it just
you know we we we wanted to be
we wanted to have it done and and
it's just i don't know just something
clicked i don't i don't i can't describe
it yeah so christy judd got he got game
on he got tasked on and then there was
no stopping it no
no
i'm grateful for yeah absolutely
absolutely that's good good stuff you
guys very very very well done who were
your biggest cheerleaders you said you
had fpu class at church right right they
were they were definitely uh uh uh huge
supporters my my parents a couple of
guys from my firehouse were huge
supporters
uh just you know friends and families
and and mainly us you know i mean you
know we talk about it to our to our
other friends and
not everybody was really interested in
it so we didn't really push the issue
and just kind of dealt with our own yeah
and that was how you got paid for house
what's the house worth uh right now
about 275 300. that's awesome that's so
cool man yeah
all right and you brought the kiddos
with you to be in the debt free screen
we got my daughter faith and my son
louis uh-huh you know
happy late
birthday you thank you
oh well done great stuff good stuff you
guys oh and she just purchased her first
car cash all right
way to go way to go
love it
and i just you know doing and doing
stuff like this and just watching our
money's helped us you know just
we've had uh right it's on the backstage
we have our 16th foster kid and it's
helped us to do stuff like that over the
years so wow you guys it's you know just
paying attention to your money and and
just you know like you say telling it
telling it where to go has really helped
us out yeah and we've we've had
education funds built up for her and for
him now yeah so she graduates nursing
school next year debt free wow
that's changing your family tree yeah
that's the stuff yeah that's awesome you
guys y'all are incredible incredible
people good job you guys good job well
done
wow good stuff all right so uh we're
gonna be a fireman and we're going to uh
own a hair salon and or cut hair right
and be foster parents we're going to
have a nurse
we're going to do all of it debt-free
and we're going to be millionaires
within the next 10 years i'm going to be
retired so we're not you know i'm not
looking at too many more uh
you'll be millionaires really well
you're on your way you got all the stuff
in place yeah copy of baby steps
millionaires for you to help you guide
you through this next part of your story
you guys are incredible you're heroes
i'm so proud of you thank you thank you
thank you so so much well done also a
copy of total money makeover for you to
give away to someone and we're gonna
give you a gift card for the uh
one year subscription to financial peace
university and every dollar through
ramsey plus and you can give that away
and get somebody else started because
you've enjoyed it already you got a lot
of stuff you can give away that way and
a lot of people are going to want to
know what you did when they find out you
paid off your house
so well done judd and christy faith and
lewis from illinois 135 000 paid off in
five years making 100 to 140. count it
down let's hear a debt-free scream ready
three
two one
that's how it's done
[Music]
man
incredible
this is the ramsey shaft
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
rachel cruz ramsey personality number
one best-selling author is my co-host
the new book is know yourself know your
money her latest number one
and um you can learn all about that and
there's assessments and all kinds of
things you can get with it check it all
out at ramseysolutions.com
frank is in sacramento hi frank welcome
to the ramsey show
well welcome thank you for having me
sure what's up
okay so
my wife and i we have a question in
regard to um
what should we do so we own a house
um we paid three about 334 for it
we think we could sell it for like 580
or more uh because of the market being
you know hot here in california we have
about a hundred thousand dollars in debt
um so we're curious it's selling the
right thing to do we'd have to rent
after that
we would have some money left over so
kind of a two-question two-part question
should i sell
a number one and number two if we did
sell with the money that's left over
after paying everything what would i do
with that money because i probably
probably wouldn't be able to buy a house
for a while okay
so you have how much debt now not
counting the house about
yeah about a hundred thousand
okay how much you guys make frank
134 collectively okay
okay and what kind of debt is the
hundred thousand
uh
car and credit card how much of its car
34.
okay so you have a hundred thousand
dollars in credit card debt no well you
know i'm sorry you have 65 000 in credit
card debt yeah wow
okay says on my screen something about
somebody following bankruptcy what's
what's going on with that
oh my wife had to file bankruptcy for
student loans
okay um uh what kind of student loans
because student loans aren't
bankruptable
well for uh
to restructure her
private loans and stuff their private
their private student loans
yeah okay and you did are they so she
went into chapter 13
correct
and how much of the students
i think about 170.
okay your wife's name's on the house i
assume right
yeah no
everything's me on me
okay i'm not positive chapter 13 is
going to go along with that
um you have to find out the legalities
on it but
she probably her marital rights in that
house in california
are probably going to cause the house
proceeds to clear up her debt
and i think i'm probably going to do
that anyway
so private student loans who are they
owed to
um
who
i'm not sure who her student loans are
owed to okay well
how long how far she was obviously way
behind
yeah well yeah yes what's her degree in
issues
uh psychology oh god okay ah
all right um so yeah
so i bought the house
and then uh
the
part of the dead is um besides the car
and everything all always in my name
yeah otherwise it would be in the
chapter 13.
100
yeah yeah her name is not only any of
this stuff or it would have been drug
into the 13.
that is correct okay
but you still ten years from today
you're still married five years from
today you're still married and she's
still in chapter 13.
and you're still trying to drag butt out
of this thing so you know it's you know
you don't have cancer your wife does but
guess what you're married to somebody
with cancer and guess what that affects
everybody in the family
um so you can't get away from this now
you are one
um in sickness and in health for richer
for poorer and all that stuff right
so it affects everybody even though it's
it's somewhat separate but that that
thing you did when you walked down the
aisle made it not separate anymore even
though legally you've got some other
weird options here
what would i do if i woke up in your
shoes i'm going to try to do the thing
that causes me to be the calmest the
wealthiest 10 years from today
not 10 months from today not what feels
good tomorrow not what is embarrassing
not what your crazy mother-in-law thinks
is smart but what makes me best off my
family overall
10 years from today i'm going to sell
the house
i'm going to negotiate with her
student loans
and try to settle them for like 120
and i'm gonna pay off everything
and be debt-free
she's no longer in bankruptcy you don't
own a house you have zero debt and
you're a renter making 134 thousand
dollars a year
breathe that piece in
now that's a place to rebuild from
okay that makes sense
but you're gonna have to get the 170
down because you don't have enough
equity to pay 100 plus 170. you only got
about 250 in equity minus your expenses
to sell 34 000 car
yeah you can sell your car that's true
good good call right right that wouldn't
be a bad idea but when i'm when i finish
all these uh machete chops all over my
life here
and this is like hacking its stuff i
mean we're just not we're not using a
scalpel here i mean we're like this is
like chainsaws and oh gosh you know i
mean this is nat you see what i'm doing
right i mean we're this is we're cutting
up here this is getting it it's like a
horror movie right so he's in the
chainsaw massacre but i mean if you're
going to go through all of that the
point is be done yeah right that's what
i'm saying
i'm going to ask you to go through that
and then sort of be done
i'd want to be clear looking at the
rearview mirror and all the crap and
start again
and you know in a sense when i went
through a chapter seven bankruptcy and
lost everything it had to start
completely over with zero and i was
actually still in debt because i still
had a stupid irs debt because you can't
get rid of them in bankruptcy either um
you know that's what i had i had almost
a clean break and the opportunity to
start over at 28 years old
and started over from there
so that's what i'm wishing for you is
that i remember how it felt
to have a lot of crap in my life but
it's all in the rearview mirror it feels
a lot better when it's on the rear view
mirror
and that's what i want for you
so yeah i would sell the house if i can
negotiate with the creditors now you
need to know that the student loans
cannot talk to her
they have they have an injunction to
stay while she's in bankruptcy it's
illegal for them to talk to her so her
attorney her bankruptcy attorney the
file chapter 13 is gonna have to do the
negotiation for you
but he can contact them and say they're
willing to sell their house and settle
this lump sum cash on the barrel head
but it's gonna you know you're gonna
have to clear this 170 for a hundred and
offer them a hundred grand on the 170
and then start from there
because here's what i know and i know
they know it you don't know this
78 of the chapter 13s fail
and go into a chapter 7.
the private student loans are
bankruptable
when the chapter 13 fails eight out of
ten times they get zero
i know this they know this yeah so they
know that you are a
zero looking for a place to happen so a
hundred grand sounds really sweet in
chapter 13 what's the time period five
years 60 months i wonder how long they
were in it for how long it's been not
long
i'm just sensing the story but yeah for
sure for sure no but um
yeah i i yeah but i
so frank you all got a a lot of pain
and a lot of mess and a lot of regret
and a lot of things you wish you could
do over if you can clean house literally
and and be done chop chop big big
swooping
swings of the machete and be done like
if you settle these student loans for
100 clear off 100 worth the other
and be a renter making 134 you're
probably going to see your income come
up in the following 12 months because
you have less stress
for the first time in your life you can
actually concentrate on each other
and on work
instead of on payments
because she's had this hanging over her
head this hundred and seventy thousand
she's been carrying around
for years the weight of it physically is
unbelievable your body is going to
change
you're gonna stand up a little
straighter your shoulders will go back a
little further
um the way you walk and talk will be
different yeah dr john delaney we talked
about this when the events about when
you owe money when you're in debt and
the deeper you are the more you probably
feel it is that your body there's a
sense of of urgency and fear
because you're not safe you're not safe
you're not safe
and you don't sleep as well i mean all
the starts having like literally the
physiological parts of your body so
clearing all of that there's a sense of
peace that that you'll get frank and
it'll be a lot
through all of this but oh so worth it
so worth it and then go make you some
money
and rebuild from there you're going to
be okay hey hang on we're going to put
you through financial peace university
is our gift to be a part of you starting
over we want to help you brother thank
you for calling call again if we can
help
[Music]
dave here you can find all of our shows
with the ramsey network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the ramsey network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsay show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw
as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host we help people
build wealth do work that they love and
that matters and create actual and
amazing relationships
rachel cruz ramsey personality number
one best-selling author is my co-host
today as we take your calls the phone
number is triple eight eight two five
five
john is with us in san antonio hey john
how are you
hey man i'm doing good thanks for taking
the call better than we deserve man
what's up
hey so my wife and i we were 28 years
old we got married when we were 20
coming we still had one year of college
had about
roughly 45 maybe 50 000 in the bank
28 now we have no debt schools paid off
and we now have
about 140 in the stock portfolio
we have about 63
in the bank account um we've got about
seven grand in hsa
we've got a roth ira that
i started with my old employer
um
so we're really just i guess i i
technically am just kind of at a point
where i'm a bit bit stifled as to as to
where we should go financially where i
should reallocate funds i don't love
that the majority of our funds are
wrapped up in the stock market
technically 37 of that 140 figure is off
to the side
but yeah just trying to figure out what
would be a responsible thing to do to
ensure that you know we're protecting
the capital gains but also yeah just
move forward in life we would like to
purchase a home but she is now a
full-time nurse
she started her nursing program right
before
2020 um and so she finished her program
while kobe was still going on but now
she's a full-time nurse um
with the aspirations of doing travel
nursing so we don't know if we want to
get locked into a home but we do think
maybe buying a town home or a condo and
then later renting that out in the san
antonio area could be a good way to make
some you know side money as we're as
we're traveling about so that's kind of
that's kind of who we are and where
we're at financially
i've done really well john for 28 years
old
so yeah yes i mean
we have and
i honestly i would say when people ask i
just say we live we don't live brutally
but we just live
responsibly um you know we're we're
just just conscientious of our purchases
and yeah we
call it we call it intentionally that's
what you've been doing you've been
interested it's really good yeah really
like a grown-up and stuff yeah
sure and so
and you said the 140
is invested
and what was that the whole
the whole 140 is not all invested
there's 37 grand uh just sitting in the
in the stock portfolio that's not being
put into anything yeah yeah yeah total
is yeah 140 just in that in that
portfolio what'd you say your household
income is
uh i didn't um so now that she's a
full-time labor and delivery nurse she's
doing night shifts so it does kind of
fluctuate typically
she brings in about 1800 per paycheck um
so i don't know ballpark we're probably
probably now around 80 85 000 a year we
were only just with my income we were
only about
45 to 50. i do maintenance for a
chick-fil-a franchise in san antonio
okay
um
yeah yeah you're making 45 to 50 and
she's making more than you think she's
making
the way you added that up i mean i think
it sounds like you have 110 000 income
to me
um
okay uh i mean labor and delivery nurse
it doesn't make 60 would shock me
um
so
all right so here's the thing you've
kind of um
with good common sense and
intentionality
have
avoided any big mistakes and created a
pile of money and now it's time to do
some fine-tuning and get on a system
that takes you
more rapidly
into uh wealth
okay yes
so that that's what i you know and the
system that we use that we have led
millions of people to become
millionaires with is called the baby
steps
and uh baby steps are to become
debt-free build an emergency fund start
putting 15 percent of your income away
uh kids college if you have kids is baby
step five and six is pay off the house
early now if i'm doing my calculations
right between the stock and the checking
account you got 200 grand you can lay
your hands on
mm-hmm that's correct i'd go buy a house
you would yeah
and i
buy about i buy about a 300 000 house
and then i pay off that 100 000 as fast
as i possibly can
and uh be done with that during the time
that you're paying off this house i want
you to start putting 15 percent of your
income away in roth iras and 401ks and
good growth stock mutual funds you have
underfunded your retirement while you're
over here playing ftse with your stock
broker
yeah you're right
okay
so stock broker is getting ready to get
cleaned out now we're going to do a
basic simple investing plan because the
two main elements i know of millionaires
that we have studied for 10 years is
that they have a paid for house and a
really nice fat juicy retirement plan
and that's the first two elements that
get them up over a million dollars and
that's where i just took you
15 of your hundred and ten thousand
going into retirement and uh a house
with only a hundred thousand dollars
owed on it you're gonna get it paid off
you'll have a paid for house by the time
you're 31. and then even if she becomes
a traveling nurse it'll happen faster go
faster but also you have a place to go
back but you wouldn't would you rent
that out
if you pay it off while they're gone are
you going to travel with her no you're
going to stay there and work on
chick-fil-a right
well so that was the thought
there's also the potential there's also
the potential so you know typically it's
based out of georgia and then trick ways
are all over the place there's a rumor
technically i've i've i've thought about
becoming my own llc
and then going from chick-fil-a to
chick-fil-a which technically i could
start doing here in san antonio market
i've got just this one franchise and i'm
under his umbrella but i could
technically you know become my own
entity and then service you know two to
three which has been duplicated or
replicated in other markets uh including
florida
you can't do that if you're jumping from
market to market
i mean you have to stay in a market a
while to do that
they don't want you working there for
three months while and then your wife
changes cities
sure yes and i think that's where it
falls apart so i think ideally yes i
would love to travel with her um but it
would you know depend on how long the
stint is if it was a three month or six
months
um you know it probably doesn't work
yeah it doesn't work and then it starts
to be do i want to be apart that much
just for some money
and probably yeah she may change her
mind when you get when you have a paid
for a house
labor delivery is not a bad gig
so um
yeah yeah i think you guys line it up
maybe the
i'm gonna put the future of the travel
nursing stuff aside for right now the
smart thing to do with the track you're
on is to get a house and pay it off as
soon as you can
uh and let's get your retirement started
at 15 of your income going into
retirement
and sit down with one of our smartvestor
pros they can help you do that at
ramseysolutions.com but you guys have
done it you've got really good common
sense
now let's put just a tinge of
sophistication with that and we'll lead
you right through this process hold on
i'm going to send you a copy of my
number one bestseller baby steps
millionaires because you're an eye blink
from being one if you'll do the stuff
i'm teaching you
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
so
[Music]
rachel cruz ramsey personality number
one best-selling author my co-host today
here on the ramsey show inflation
is affecting everyone
from the gas pump to the grocery store
and while you can't control what happens
with the economy you can control what
happens with your money
when you panic and you freak out and you
justify
based on the craziness out there that
you go crazy
you don't help anything
you have to get
really calm
really wise
move a little slower
step away from the amazon button
don't push submit
don't push buy now buy now just add the
cart just add the car don't even add it
don't even have a cart don't add
anything to the cart now life is much
better see we just controlled your
budget
now mr bezos budget might get squeezed
but he can handle it better than you can
handle it the only way to control your
money in uncertain times is on a budget
the best way to do the budget is with
every dollar you plan out your monthly
budget give every dollar a name before
the month begins
and you track all your expenses through
the month
every dollar mobile app lets you check
your budget from anywhere so you can
always make the right money decisions
when you get on a budget you will be in
total control of your money start
budgeting for free by going to
ramseysolutions.com
every dollar
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five kelly is in
charlotte north carolina hi kelly
welcome to the ramsey show
hello to both of you thank you for
taking my call
sure what's up i i am a fairly new widow
a role that nobody really expects to be
in and i just wanted to take a moment to
tell anyone out there who does not have
life insurance to get it wow you are not
you're not immune to whatever this world
has to do out to you and no one is
immune to the word never i'm so sorry
what happened
um cancer
how old was he
he was just 52.
i'm so sorry how long were y'all married
25 years we won 10 pounds during the
gulf war so hats off to the former
people who had their doing their debt
free screen it's a it's a an amazing
role yeah but um i just wanted to
i'm having trouble kind of grasping and
honoring
the work that he and i both did to have
what we had to put away
to roll over to iras and what have you
into retirement and watching it
go in the market that we're in now
i've you know i've lost
a little over 11 percent so far in what
i had
and i know that that's um not near what
others have lost i'm very blessed in
that regard but i'm just having trouble
did yourself
no and you haven't lost it
no no i didn't show it value is down
your value is down but you haven't lost
any money until you sell it
correct and i know that from listening
to you yes sir i know that from
listening to you how much money is it
how much money is in this account kiddo
just shy of 400 000. okay cool good
and what do you make
um i i make 40. okay when did he pass
about a year ago about a year and two
months ago okay and was there life
insurance in addition to this 400
there was um it wasn't 10 to 12 times
his income just because um i had already
always asked him to get life insurance
every birthday every christmas that kind
of thing and he finally did a year
before so when we were able to
all we could afford and given his
health at that point it was about half
of what it should have been
so how much life insurance was there
there was 500 000
and where is that
with that i have paid off the house
and i paid off all of our bills
including all the medical bills
paid for the funeral
i had i gave some money to his family
and i also have someone set aside to get
to get our last
child through college
he gave some money to his family
yeah they were they were estranged and
i just felt like it was something i
needed to do
so
i gave some to each of his siblings wow
okay how much did you give estranged
siblings
um i gave each of them five thousand
dollars
okay so 20 total okay wow
all right and so
how much of that after you did all of
that is there any of that life insurance
money left or is it all there
it's um there's still some left um i
have what i need to get my friend
through school when i have them for um
upgrades i need to make not upgrades but
things i need to do around the house
gotcha can you live on what you make
um i'm i'm squeaking down i'm i am
having trouble getting the 15
each month for retirement you know to
put toward retirement but um
hopefully i'll be able to squeeze things
and make it make it happen what do you
do kelly for a living
um
well i was trained as a copywriter
um advertising marketing writer and then
i came home to be with the kids i did
some freelance
and then um when steven got sick we were
having trouble paying for the medical
bills so i went back to work just as in
an admin role and that's where i've been
for about five years okay all right
and i'm sorry i've been writing stuff
down trying to crack it in my head again
how long ago did he pass
a year and two months okay all right i'm
sorry for what you've been through
you've done a really really good job in
a very
tragic stressful
situation
you've
really done a good job
i'm sorry
it's like totally just fun too yeah yeah
you've done you've just done a really
good job
i mean
it's hard to it's hard to be as smart as
you've been while you're
can't breathe
and you got you know you're the grief
that you've been dealing with and
everything
i can still hear it in your voice but
you still made good wise decisions so
um well and i thank you for that i know
i didn't know you didn't say that i know
but i couldn't have done it without your
leadership at all so let me just say
that okay so here's what i would tell
you to do um
let's uh
not put money in retirement for one year
let's just push pause on the baby steps
okay
and that'll give you time to get your
career adjusted
get your income up get your budget
dialed in
to where you can breathe a little bit
and just give yourself room to cry a
little
okay
okay we don't have to tighten everything
up and do everything perfect you don't
have a house payment
you don't have any payments
you don't have anybody bothering you the
kid's college is covered all your
financial stress is gone
because of the work that he did you did
and that's the way you honor him
as you continue and play through
there's not a a certain movement or a
certain rhythm that's different
the way you honor it is you go this is
what he would have done if he was here
this is what we would have done if he
was here
and so that's the way you honor him as
you play on through now what i do want
you to give yourself a little room
because you've not given yourself any
room to breathe yet
i mean you've been just hanging on
hanging on pushing dialing in trying to
do the right thing
fighting cancer and then and then
fighting grief and then you know
collecting money and then from the
insurance then paying off the house and
you just been execute execute execute
execute
breathe stop relax
for a year
and give your heart that is broken time
to heal
you'll have plenty of time to start your
retirement
now let me tell you what's magical about
this
if you have the 400k that's invested in
good growth stock mutual funds
if it averages 10 percent every seven
years it's going to double if you add
nothing to it
so you're 52 at 59 it'll be 800
at 66 it'll be 1.6
so you stopping retirement for a year
it's not going to bother a thing
at 73 it's 3.2
okay you stopping retirement for one
year is not going to cause you to retire
broke i don't want you to stop it
forever i do want you to get back in the
rhythm of investing after your broken
heart is healing a little more
but right now i hear a lady who hasn't
stopped yet
and had time to cry enough are you
hearing that
yeah i mean kelly you've done a
phenomenal job but i think just
taking a break break and resting i think
is is wise advice um and it may clear
your mind and even maybe even get your
income up during the year or two i think
you'll probably reassess your career
while you're doing this this year i
think that's what's going to naturally
happen
it's part of your healing
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
rachel cruz ramsey personality is my
co-host open phones at
825-5225 in the lobby of ramsey
solutions on the debt free
stage
zayn and jc are with us hey guys how are
you good how are you better than we
deserve so how much debt did you two pay
off
uh thirty thousand dollars good how long
did that take just barely over a year
one year all right and your range of
income during that time we started at
about a hundred and ended at 175. good
yes what do y'all do for a living um me
and my dad are in the used car business
and i've been a good year
best year we've ever had
and i'm going to grad school i'm
currently a stay-at-home mom but i'm
finishing my degree okay
very good good
so where do you guys live
popper bluff missouri all right good
good what kind of debt was the 30k
student loans mainly
we had about um 27.5 in uh student loans
and then the rest of it was credit card
debt okay and it was you he's pointing
at you yes yes unfortunately um he
actually he was big into
all of your books and everything
beforehand so he graduated graduated
debt-free um so most of the student
loans were mine
okay and so how long y'all been married
two years okay so a little after
marriage you come home and say we're
doing this we're getting out of debt
took him a little while to get you all
figured out how crazy he really was what
you had married into tell me the story
what happened well i actually had known
beforehand that he was really into this
um because we did fpu when we were
dating oh wow yeah so uh you're hardcore
thing yes he broke me in so we were the
youngest people in the room
but uh but yeah so um we did fpu and
then we went to um actually it was uh
what was it the money marriage and money
event that rachel had put on a couple
years ago yeah yeah so yeah uh so we
went to that and then we really wanted
to pay off debt um prior to being
married so we went ahead and took care
of the credit card debt prior to getting
married and then afterwards we wanted to
wait to
have kids we wanted to actually like go
ahead and have all of our debt paid off
before then but you know life doesn't
work that way and we ended up getting
pregnant with our son and so we tried to
pay off as much debt as we could before
we had him um but we did take a break
and we cash flowed his birth just in
case yeah good good and your cash flow
and your your master's right yes okay
good of course you are yeah
very good good for you guys how old are
you two 25 and 24. and your everything's
paid for mm-hmm other than the house
other than that yeah everything but the
house good that's a how's your feet
good really good what do you tell people
the key to getting out of debt is you
did it 30 000 bucks man
you know being on the same page and
contentment is
probably the biggest thing
i think discipline too i think it was
really uh interesting for me
like rachel always talks about budgeting
like you're spending money because that
was a big thing between us on our budget
and i always wanted to have that for
myself just in case you know
for self-care but but yeah just
including that in the budget was
important for me
to make it's to make life realistic
right in this process because yes you
want to sacrifice your lifestyle and get
ahead but also you want to be realistic
of
living today right so that's amazing you
guys great job so did people think y'all
were crazy
being so young and i wonder if people
what your friends said well we didn't
really talk about it a whole lot but
yeah i don't know that anybody ever said
we was crazy i don't think they said we
were crazy they just they were not on
the same page especially a lot of kids
our age you know they're not really
into you know doing that or paying off
their student loans you know so that was
one thing that it was different that we
were doing than other kids our age yes
for sure for sure amazing amazing you
guys so who are the biggest cheerleaders
i'd say our family probably yeah okay
good way to go you guys way to go
awesomeness you're heroes man thank you
and you got a new baby that come in the
picture right
and uh what a name and age
hudson and he's 15 months all right 15
month young guy i love it perfect
perfect perfect
that's a lot of fun they're they're a
riot at 15.
we got a couple of them hanging out
around there oh charles is about two and
his little cousin eli is about one
so yeah they're hanging out in a
lot of drama yeah it's good stuff good
stuff a lot of fun well you guys are fun
congratulations heroes thank you you did
it you did it you did it you did it you
did it it's very very important very
cool so in the used car business what
are you seeing with the prices
uh straight up yeah up until probably
maybe a month two months ago we were on
nothing but a
straight upward path but i think it's we
started to level off again
okay
so that the orig the increases have
stuck so far it hasn't come back down it
started coming back down yeah i haven't
seen that okay and you there's just more
supply now more more stuff available
i wouldn't even say that i mean
maybe the interest rates and gas prices
and stuff a little bit uncertainty right
now slowed everything down yeah we'll
see we'll see in the next quarter how it
does got you okay good fun i'm glad to
get a little insight from an expert here
i know i'm just seeing that moment
i see her and she's like okay we got
this we got it
let's just make it a couple more minutes
you can do it all right we got a copy of
the baby steps millionaires book for you
that's the next chapter in your story
total money makeover book and a year
subscription to financial peace
university and every dollar plus
included all in a ramsey plus
subscription so we'll get all of that to
you way to go guys very proud of you
well done
zane jc and eight or uh
14 month old was it hudson
poplar bluff missouri 30 000 paid off in
one year making 100 to 175 count it down
let's hear a debt-free scream three two
one we're debt-free
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
great
very well done you guys were just
chatting about cars and the car market
and i see her she's like okay we can do
this
he's not gonna he's not gonna melt down
he's not gonna melt down sweet
national radio
he was looking around trying to figure
out what he did that he got clapped for
yeah because everybody everybody all the
audience is clapping out in the in the
lobby so
good stuff great very good i love it
love it love it
well i feel like all the debt free
screams this show
it has it's been
a range of incomes a range of debt
levels but it's still that consistent
what we see time and time again when
people choose to change their life
change their money habits change the way
they've been doing what they'd always
been doing
and they actually work the plan
together together it works there's
always this together thing there's
always the plan thing and there's always
this commitment a switch flips to commit
to follow through that's right and do it
you have to as a friend of mine said to
me he said i've been following your
stuff for 10 years i never did it and he
said then i made the decision to submit
myself that's a strong word
in a culture where no one is you know to
tell me what to do
submit yourself
to a different way of doing things
continuing to do the same thing over and
over again expecting a different result
is the definition of insanity
submit yourself
to a new way of doing things and it
changes everything absolutely absolutely
yeah so i you know i it's been widely
reported by me
that during covet i got unbelievably fat
and i ate every donut in a 50 mile
radius and so i had to submit myself
to a different methodology on eating
and i you know i got a hold of an app
and i started counting calories counting
steps and i started walking and running
again and i haven't missed a running or
walking day in
780 days good night no
i promise you i'll show you on the app
haven't watched that dave math no not
dave at all i haven't missed a single
one that's impressive no i take that
back i missed three days when i was sick
with coving okay i didn't miss three
days
that's a good experience i was in the
bed i'll give you that experience that's
amazing snow rain sleet i don't miss
because because i don't want to break i
don't break the streak yeah and i have
consistently logged now 2300
meals consecutive
do you track every meal
every meal and i lost you know
consequently i lost 42 pounds what did i
do my point is not to brag on me i
submitted myself to a system
yeah that you know exercise and less
intake of calories and it's magical you
lose weight didn't it you know i mean
it's just whoa where'd you get that idea
you know it's just live on less than you
make live on less than you make and
you'll have money
where'd you get that man you guys ought
to like do a podcast
yeah this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
our scripture of the day hebrews 12 14
make every effort to live in peace with
everyone and to be holy without holiness
no one will see the lord
ben franklin said a good example
is the best sermon
amen nathan is with us nathan's in
california hi nathan welcome to the
ramsey show
hi guys thank you for taking my call
sure what's up
so i'm 19 i live with my parents and i'm
just trying to tackle my car that my
parents sent me up for a car loan
like when i was 18.
and so i have 12k left of it it's a good
car it's not like fancy anything and i'm
just wanting to pay it off
and then i wanted to pay for my college
in cash so my question is
how much money of my income should i
save to pay for my school in cash and
like should i save more than that or
should i save just the amount to pay for
my school
yeah that's a great question nathan what
what kind of job do you have right now
right now i just have a part-time job
working on a brewery um but it brings in
like a good amount i get like 2 000 some
of the months okay
what does it take to go to school
um i'm splitting it with my mom every
semester so be about like
1
200
that's the tuition
yeah and you're living at home
no other big expenses
books
just my car and then obviously insurance
and then they make me pay like 150
dollars just for rental tips like yeah
how much how much could you get for the
car now nathan
um like how much is it
like how much is it if i sold it yeah
i think it'd be like 7 000 then
obviously i'd still have to pay you 0012
yeah i owe 12 on it that's not possible
you screwed something up
you didn't buy you didn't buy it one
year ago and it has gone down that much
during the last year used cars have gone
up
did you pay 12 for it did you pay 12 000
for it
no no no we um the loan is has 12 left
on it and then no it doesn't you're
confused what did you pay for the car
how much was the car knew
we went to the dealership and i remember
being 14 and now it's at 12. like that's
my remaining balance okay then it's not
worth seven it's probably worth 12 or
13.
oh you're right you're eight yeah yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
one of these numbers was wrong dude
that's what i was trying to figure out
okay
so all right so you've got a car that
you owe what on it roughly on it what
it's worth and you're making two
thousand dollars a month and you're
responsible for twelve hundred dollars
of tuition plus books plus gas plus 150
bucks
right
so you can save your tuition every two
months
600 a month out of 2000 going towards
tuition every two months you'd have a
tuition payment now the 1200 is is one
semester and you're going two semesters
or three a year
i'm going just two semesters a year okay
so you need you need twenty four hundred
dollars
for tuition correct
yes per year
twenty four thousand yeah per year no
twenty four hundred hundred hundred or
thousand yeah five hundred oh twelve
hundred dollars my comma was wrong in my
notes twelve hundred dollars
plus twelve hundred dollars twenty four
hundred and you're making 24 000 a year
and you need 2 400
to go to school correct
okay so you should you should be able to
pay the car off and go to school in one
year
closer yes so how much do you think then
um my monthly thing will be on the car
right a thousand
a thousand dollars a month
and you'll be done in one year let's
just do a little math okay let's take
two thousand
minus a thousand dollars a month on the
car that leaves us a thousand bucks
okay
and if we're going to put the tuition
out evenly over 12 months we would need
to save 200 a month to buy to have 2400
for one year correct
correct okay
so that leaves us 800 bucks
minus 150
you following me for rent
i'm doing your budget in front of you
okay for sure
another 150 for my car insurance okay
well so let's just take 300 off 800 now
we got 500. you still got to buy gas
still got to buy gas and you still got
to buy books
yeah and you're going to blow a tire and
that's 500
that's good yeah
so but it's probably not going to be
quite that smooth that you do an even
200 a month for
the uh the uh uh
tuition because you're probably gonna
have to do like 600 and 600 over two
months and then not have any tuition
savings and put the difference towards
your car so put a little less on the
tuition savings months on the car and a
little more on the non-tuition saving
months have four tuition saving months
of 600 a year
right that makes sense i'm gonna have
some i have around like three thousand
of my savings right now
that could go towards the um
tuition as well oh okay something that
should be good and then don't we we
don't need to worry about tuition we got
tuition covered for a year
so for right now let's start let's start
putting 1200 a month on the car until
the car is gone you'll be done in 10
months
okay
that doesn't freak out like me taking
stuff out of my savings and it's like
and it's gonna be around to like a
thousand once i'm done with this year's
school and it's like
yeah but now if you have three thousand
and a year school is 2400 you have 600
left and well paid for school and i have
a paid for car in ten months
all right
that's true
but you're saying it doesn't feel like
enough
is what you're saying work more
right
yeah i just don't want to get too much
like because um like i don't i don't
want my settings to be too low you know
because you say a thousand something
nathan i mean i know it feels like i
didn't say take your savings down to a
thousand i said pay your tuition out of
your savings
but then that would take it down to a
thousand is what he's saying oh no it
needs to you need to you just pay your
tuition out of savings and during and
you're not going to go below because
dude you when's the next tuition payment
fall
july
okay okay july and then when's the next
one after that
i believe it's january so yeah yeah i
got plenty of time yeah so your car will
be paid off before you have another
tuition payment
after july so you won't go below
best news all day
so just this all we're doing with you
sir is we're just walking you through
planning all this out on paper and when
you plan it all out on paper i don't
care how many zeros are involved your
piece level goes up and your stress
level goes down
and that's all we're doing here because
you could you can hear it in his voice
as soon as we start going oh there's a
way to do this dad come well and here's
the deal to nathan you're 19
and from the information you just gave
me i bet your parents are wonderful but
they signed you up for a car payment at
18. so they're probably not
well they're probably not like on this
plan possibly yeah i think uh
so all that to say though nathan at 19
number one i applaud you for calling in
and number two i think you need to go
through ramsay plus get you a membership
uh if you hold on the line austin will
pick up and get you a year membership
yeah yeah yeah yeah we'll go charge you
because he's stressed out about it no
we're not no no i'm giving it to you
because in it is going to be every
dollar which is going to be the
budgeting app it's going to be financial
peace university and you want to soak in
be a sponge nathan to this money stuff
because if you didn't grow up with it
you're kind of flying at the city of
your pants and figuring this out right
so replay this call and replay this call
when it comes out on youtube
and continue to just know okay here are
my numbers here's what's going on and be
intentional nathan this stuff is easy to
understand it it's not going to be that
difficult i promise doing it and living
life out of it is hard because your
behavior has to change
and you're going to take on these new
money habits but the beautiful thing is
you're doing it at 19. nathan you're not
out of control you are very mature
you're thinking ahead you actually
called a show like this you work hard
and you have reasonable tuition and a
good living situation you have
everything in your favor
you're gonna win
you're gonna win big but just be doing
it on purpose lay everything out map out
these cash flows out of 12 months out
and that will show you that all i gotta
do is execute then and i you know 10 by
christmas dude you got your car is
almost paid off
and you're done
i mean this is where you're going to be
so you're going to be just fine you're
doing really really good that puts us
our the ramsey show in the books we'll
be back with you before you know it in
the meantime remember there's ultimately
only one way to financial peace and
that's to walk daily with the prince of
peace christ jesus
[Music]
dave here you can find all of our shows
with the ramsey network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the ramsey network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
you